So we just established that alcohol was a drug that can build up in the body,
and exert intoxicating effects, but how does it do this? Well, alcohol
has specific targets, for example the neurotransmitter
GABA receptors, are really important in the
brain and central nervous system. Alcohol can
physically bind to the GABA receptor and
enhance its function in signaling inside the
cell. This is referred to as pharmacodynamics,
what a drug does to a body. The direct targets, the target effects of the
drug. The physical binding of alcohol to
the GABA receptor. Activates this neurotransmitter pathway,
which results in relaxation, and slower reaction
times. So based on this information, which of
the following mutations of the GABA receptor do you
think would result in a pharmacodynamic change were the
person would experience increased relaxation and slower reaction times?
Go ahead and pick which answer you think is best.